yeah I love by the way this is my
favorite [ __ ] like I don't like usually
doing work to all the jokes about decks
and stuff but like if you ask me what my
favorite [ __ ] to do at Wine Library is
every time I have to go back in and fix
it every year this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
real this is [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
with you heavy right you must have
looked at this and be like you want it
you'll love this you know what is the
hidden one on this cuz that's the math
and I get it just macro energy the
energy of it all just the energy of it
all the hidden to the math is easy to
understand you cut these that it's so
black and white it's the gray it's the
this this color the million things that
we can Tibet I don't even know your
business well enough to know like just
the space that's taking up the call it
late cause operational like and I would
again say but I'll say it again I'll say
it again my friend
it's the operational grey not black and
white I understand that you have to have
to warehouse guys who have to pick it up
I'm talking about thinking like this
stuff you can't think of like Oh like
the you know the dye that goes into that
color the supplier like fainted like
like [ __ ] that you never think about
yeah just like the [ __ ] that gets [ __ ]
up when you have too many people like
just the reality of it the meetings the
meetings the [ __ ] meeting the meeting
for the meeting goes down tremendously
when you have a lot less SKUs it's
amazing how that actually works the
other thing you can do is with to me
when you decide to do something with
this let's say you're like go rogue and
you're like [ __ ] it we're getting rid of
the 15% SKUs even that to me gives the
opportunity I'm always on the offense
this is why we never make any profit
here I would be like hey
talk about like macro being chaotic I'd
be like let's start a second site a deal
the de site on the 15% cuz we're gonna
liquidate it and maybe by accident it
turns into the thing so this is where I
kind of like like this is how my
businesses work like they'll do
everything right
like this is all right then I'll add
this extra thing cuz you got to build
out a new site and is it so it takes
away all the savings I do it because
it's offense because god forbid that
then becomes the thing like it happened
in the wine business in the wine
business the way Wine Library got
disrupted after I left was deal the day
sites popped up
you know wines are sold out at last
bottom we have one called Cinderella
wine but like those companies came in
were nice little cute things until they
became the market right so you know like
I think the 15 purse
it becomes the biggest piece of content
maybe it's like the you like you know
like discontinued or my favorite thing
like what was that Brooklyn nine-nine
got canceled by Fox and NBC picked it up
make sure if you decide to do something
on this to do something with the
elimination of the 15% you may find out
that even though it was only a small
brand there was so much passion around
this one color or one SKU and that
becomes a whole thing in itself like got
it like coca-cola
disaster with new coke but actually
helped them for the next 20 years
because coke classic got a bump even
though they were I feel like it's got it
so there's an opportunity in the elimin
you don't
too many people quietly just eliminate
these 15% instead of using it as an
opportunity and maybe spark the
innovation of opportunity got it that's
where I am a little bit different that's
where my creative aspect be its mental
well yeah I wouldn't say that no I would
say it's more I think New Coke is the
thing like or the deal of the day site
like these guys are entrepreneurs so
this is very exciting to me and I think
I think that what's great about
entrepreneurs that's different than
L'Oreal is the idea I just had is
exactly right for entrepreneurs because
it's our natural state like that sounds
fun and it right that sounds like yes
and I do believe in opportu the 15% that
they're gonna discontinue promotionally
done right could lead to one skew in
that fifth
becoming the number one SKU in 2019
because there was community management
outrage of the discontinued Nisour enjoy
some and then they come back and be like
guys we've heard you orange blossom is
back and it was like what the [ __ ] is
orange blossom because it was never
selling but the email that goes to
everybody they go back and watch the
YouTube video they're like oh my god I
almost this guy need it and all of a
sudden you wake up and the number 2 SKU
that's driving your business is orange
blossom see where I'm going I know what
my role is very way from you guys on
this part please personally I'm a little
depressed I'm like kind of sad because
it's been eye-opening right I mean
honestly bro you should have like you
should be pumped I love the last 15
months at Vayner where I've had to do a
lot of defense and cleanup stuff I've
enjoyed it like it's like it's poor it's
what you sign up for like you should
it's just think about this this is what
I always do like whenever and I'm
pointing to them because they're just
like senior executives whenever it's the
most depressing of our meetings like
we're gonna lose money this year and
like and that and the notion is like
like ultimately when you're the CEO it's
your fault like there's no confusion my
end I mean you know the thing I always
remind them no matter what I'm like yeah
but how we get here and like I know by
the way we do and meter up dollars in
sales like we're not like you know she
like to me it's actually complete
optimist I'm like [ __ ] you've been able
to you know how hard it is to build a
business doing eight figures like you've
done that and you've done nothing right
it's kind of like how I used to do but
like I would say myself we've done this
and we're not even doing anything right
yet I think it's awesome you know maybe
I'm a little optimistic but like I do
think you need to take in that place oh
yeah yeah it's just spiritually he's
gonna make you climb a mountain soon be
careful like overall it's like it's just
the level of sophistication that it's
bringing to our business if he is
[ __ ] insane and it's true it's like
we've literally muscled our way to this
point willed it yeah we will
thoughtful will is super exciting do I
have you sustained eight-figure after
year it also means that in a world where
there's so much opportunity there's a
couple of core things that are really
special right like I had a meeting today
and they're like what's the twitch
studio about one of our creatives and I
was like well that's the part that's
special about us for all the things we
are and aren't that the reason Vayner is
going to destroy everyone is you have a
CEO who's willing to build a twitch
studio outside of his office like that
will always play out so what you need to
also do through this process is ask
yourselves why have we been able to get
to eight figures and sustain it in there
is the secret sauce of the Big Mac sure
the Big Macs frozen sure nobody wants to
eat fast food anymore but still that
secret sauce is real so I in so like
it's a figuring out what to do here but
it's also be like why the [ __ ] did this
work okay cool let's let's scale even
more of that or let's put that on a
pedestal so that everybody likes goes to
that North Star too and I've got just
sheer will of like family business and
that's fine too
it capture more that's why I don't let
that ever get broken here Dennis in my
limited time here what's the best you
somewhat like what what from your
perspective no worries no worries no
worries well then if we're gonna do that
back to the younger part it's all
fifteen-year-old influencers I have a
humongous recommendation faced is like
go on it like now you did this
the next pillar I would do if I owned
this business is I would go on an
aggressive Roadshow of thank you economy
against number one on objectives I would
look at my business and I would
literally fly to Omaha and sit down with
the owner of the warehouse for the
distributor I would fly to like now go
deepest [ __ ] in building the
relationship with the top customers you
have in human form get to them not the
convenience of a trade show not when
they happen to be in town
at the time allocate the time to go and
show that just the shear execute even
the attempt of if they like canceled
twice cuz they're busy even the attempt
of is gonna be massively ROI positive
flat-out I'm here like I'm here on a
mission to reverse-engineer how to make
your business better if I is a supplier
and making your business better my
business with you will grow you set up
that framework of a conversation got it
having one launched every year I think
that ties into aggressively speaking to
existing customers to find out like
we're going to be innovating what can
you like how could we want you to
influence our next innovation or or
making a big deal of it and doing two
dinners a year that you fly people into
and you do the presentation of the
innovation just seven people about you
know Steve Jobs his first wooden
computer with Steve was nine people in a
[ __ ] classroom later it was [ __ ]
the world watching on livestream gotta
start somewhere
fly seven people in give him a nice
dinner Canada let them you know pop up
in a nice Okanagan Pinot Noir and some
up in the skill and ice wine and make
them feel like the really part of this
like this is a thing couldn't agree with
you couldn't agree with you more
it's an event it's an event it's why we
through voice con by throwing the party
it's the high school party rule if you
throw the party you have the leverage
people don't really know they watch your
content when they meet the team it's
like holy [ __ ]
it's really powerful
it's really funny yeah I mean if you
watch my concert to your point like I
don't think people even understand
forget about even how amazing the team
is and the capabilities I don't think
people understand they hear vaynermedia
but they have no sense of but Lee this
is one of our four offices like this you
know like so cool you're welcome in